- What up, vlog?
Just did a workout.
Anyway, one of the more
interesting jam sessions
I've had in a while is with
the uber-talented Big K.R.I.T.
If you haven't listened
to his new double album,
go check it.
Hope you guys are doing super
well on this holiday weekend
and getting geared up
for that December crunch.
Check it, watch it, thank you
so much for being subscribed.
Actually, a lot of you aren't.
Subscribe now if you're not.
(hip hop music)
- [Big] Yo yo.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Big] How are you doing, my brother?
- Real pleasure.
- Same to you.
- [Gary] How are you, my man?
- [Big] Doing good, doing good.
- Yeah, real pleasure.
Hey, how are you?
- Great, nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure, how you doing?
- Doing great, man, doing great.
- Come on, sit sit sit, get comfortable.
What's up, man?
How you doing?
- Man, how are you?
Kari.
- Kari.
- Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure, how are you?
- I'm good.
- Good.
How you doing, my man?
- [Man] What's up, what's going on?
(mumbling)
- [Woman] Thank you.
(giggling)
- What's up, my man?
(mumbling)
We got WWF belts up here.
- How you doing?
Shawn Marshall pleasure to meet you.
- Gary Vaynerchuk, how are you?
- Pleasure to meet you, Gary.
- How are things?
(mumbling)
Thank you, my man.
This is the room.
- [Big] Yeah!
(laughing)
I was like, bro.
Ah, man, I respect it, bro.
- How you doing?
- I'm good, brother.
Excited.
- Good man.
It's a real pleasure to meet you.
I've been looking forward to it.
- [Big] Thank you, same for you.
- Yeah man, how's life?
- Great.
Obviously, uploading the
album, but just being back out
and moving around and seeing
people I ain't seen in years.
More like a family reunion kind of thing,
and everybody's grown
and changed and worked
through stuff, and it's
just like catching back up.
And it's like that man, glad
you're back, kind of thing.
- [Gary] It's a good feeling, right?
- Ah man, it's refreshing.
It's refreshing to be outta the studio
and just be living it.
(laughing)
- How long were you in the studio?
- [Big] I worked on it for
two hours, I mean two years.
Two years.
- Yeah, Jesus.
- I lived, I just lived that album.
And so, once it came, when I turned it in
and gave it to my man
(mumbling), it was hard
for me to let go of the fact
that I didn't have anything
to do at the moment.
'Cause I was so used to just--
- [Gary] It felt awkward, right?
- Definitely.
Calling him, like Brett,
what you need me to do.
Like Brett, you don't have any shit.
It's okay, bro.
It's good.
- [Gary] Where do you live?
- In Atlanta.
Yeah, I'm in Atlanta.
And yeah man, this is different.
This is fun.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Yeah, brother, yeah.
- [Gary] How long are you in New York?
- We'll be around?
- [Man] Until Thursday.
- 'Til Thursday.
- [Gary] Got a lot of promotion
and all that kind of stuff.
- Making it happen.
(mumbling)
Yeah, but see, trying to eat better.
Not doing too much.
Lost some weight, I can make the runs
when I'm tripping.
- [Gary] I get it.
- I ain't, yeah, we can make the runs.
(laughing drowning out speakers)
Now, mind you, right, I
know you always on the move,
on the go, and so, brother, sleep.
Like how often (mumbling)?
- My man, sleep is important.
I'm not worried about how
many hours people sleep.
I'm worried about what they're
doing when they're awake.
I'm trying to get six, seven, eight hours.
The body is not joking around.
I got a little bit of a,
I was just complaining,
I'm going to Australia
next week for two days,
and I'm only sleeping two hours.
I don't know what my
assistant was thinking, but,
in general, but in general, in general,
I get scared when people
think the whole hustle mantra
that I like to push is about not sleep.
Because I'm trying to talk more about it,
that's why I have this good
line, like I'm not worried
about what you do when you're asleep,
I'm worried about what
you do when you're awake,
just so people get it.
But yeah, to me it's when you're awake.
It's those 18 hours that
really, really matter.
People are just wasting their at bat.
- [Big] Man!
Hey, I like that.
You're on deck, you wait, you
try to get your opportunity
and you're too tired to
hit the goddamn ball.
- 100%, and then you prefer
to sit and dwell and complain.
People just come up with a
million reasons why not to do.
(laughing)
Right?
Do you know Prince worked as
a janitor for studio time?
Do you know that?
- [Big] Did not know that.
- [Man] Did not know that.
- That to me gets me fired the
fuck up because I don't know,
I assume you get plenty of
this, too, in DM and all this,
but obviously since, I
just get so many kids
who wanna be you, and they're like, a lot
of them don't have much, and I'm like,
work at Chick-fil-A, save
your money, go to the studio.
- [Big] Exactly.
- I don't know.
What do you want me to tell you?
- [Big] Or become a hybrid
and don't just do one thing
in your field.
- Well, that's that next, that's...
And then what's even crazier,
actually, is the shit
you can now do that doesn't
even need studio time.
It's just like.
It's not what you and
I grew up with, right?
I mean the technology's crazy,
do you know what this is?
- [Big] I know what you, a studio.
- This is a studio.
That's exactly what it is.
(laughing)
It's just suffocating out excuses.
- [Big] Oh my god!
- Right, right?
- [Big] Yo, you right.
- So, what's going on
with your guy's team?
Obviously, I know you guys
have enough context for us.
I've seen different outreaches.
We've talked, I've watched,
we've talked, listened.
Is there anything that over,
since we got time together,
is there anything that
stands out that I can answer,
I can help with?
Is there anything we can do?
And please, go ahead.
And as the person that
probably has the most context
on both sides, feel free.
- So, real quick, right--
- [Gary] You got some
new, cool shoes, huh?
- [Big] Oh, he's like oh, hey.
(laughing)
- No, real fast, though, when
I first started working here--
- I know exactly what you're about to say.
- He was just telling
me that that interview
we did messed up his
whole album, 'cause we had
to turn the volume down
to do the interview,
and they bounced the
album and it was too soft,
and everyone's like why is so soft?
I need to turn my headphones up.
- [Big] Everybody's
wondering why I dropped it.
K.R.I.T. Wuz Here and
it's so low in the car.
But when he walked in, we
pushed the master fader down
and so we could the album--
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- Bounce that shit, and I told
him, yo, you're the reason.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
That's amazing.
- I want everybody
in the world!
I believe in my music being
loud as shit, knocking.
Like uh!
You might be the reason why I
made the sub loud as shit now.
(laughing)
- [Gary] It's gotten a
inch louder 'cause of you.
- It's like yeah.
- The crazy thing is
that's like 2010, right?
And then he's like on
Def Jam, doing his thing,
and now he's off Def Jam, independent,
doing his thing independently,
and he's at this
cool position, I feel,
because in the year 2017,
he has all the fans, he
has all the attention.
He knows the value of attention.
He knows the value of shaking
hands and being face to face.
But he doesn't have a
label controlling him.
- Some people are just
naturally charismatic
and like people.
And that's the biggest fucking
advantage if you have that.
- [Big] Being human, yeah.
- And he's one of the smarter
musicians we've met with.
- [Big] Thank you.
- Musically.
It's just the truth.
- He says that to everybody, don't worry.
(laughing drowning out speakers)
Just trying to help you here.
- [Big] You gonna get some calls.
- I'm gonna make a highlight
reel of every meeting we have.
It's just the same thing.
But, go ahead.
- For real.
I know you well enough to know.
From what angle?
'Cause your next follow up is gonna--
- Musically.
- Yes.
Musically.
- Famous jazz musician here
and listen to his album,
he's gonna be like wow!
You know what I mean?
- I understand.
- And also, lyrically--
- 'Cause I'm funny, as a
person that listens to music.
And this is the reason I love hip hop,
it's less about production
and music and beats.
It is.
It's so much more about the words.
- [Big] Yeah.
- I just resonate with it,
'cause I'm competitive,
I came up with not much.
To me, my media empire looks
a lot more like slinging disks
from the back of a truck and that's why I,
that's why I resonate with it.
So, every time, the music
parts always funny to me,
'cause I never wanna front,
and be like oh yeah yeah.
I don't really know.
I love Metro Boomin, like him.
But to understand his craft
versus somebody who writes,
there's a big disconnect for me.
I don't understand music...
I like what you--
- [Big] I respect that!
- That's just not what I do.
Like telling you how to make
sure every single eSports kid
on earth fucks with
you, that I understand.
Making sure that every
Latino 14-year-old guy fucks
with you so that in 10 years,
when they're the majority
of the US market, that I can tell you.
How to hack Singapore, to
when you go over there,
and you're the number
one, that I understand.
But understanding...
When people are like that bass,
I'm like, yeah, that bass.
I don't understand that.
I understand it, but
I don't understand it.
It doesn't go through me like that.
- Yeah.
I dig it, but I think, to some degree--
- [Gary] How 'bout why do you think that?
Did you grow up in a musical family?
- Ah man, as far as
being around my parents
and my grandmother and them
playing different music--
- [Gary] Always, it's always the answer.
- Obviously gospel and blues,
and my dad playing Scarface.
And I'm getting that from him.
And my mom is playing Whitney Houston.
So, I got all those things.
And then I sought out music on my own.
And then you talking
about old school records,
and people that I like, and
discovering Curtis Mayfield
and Bobby Womack, or Willie Hutch.
Then that's how I got the brand of--
- And what about, so that's classic.
And so what about new, when
you were, how old are you?
- [Big] I'm 31.
- You look good.
- [Big] Thank you, hey, I'm trying.
I grew the hair out.
- That's what helped you.
- [Big] I look younger now
then I did when I was 21.
- D Wade the other day, I
was watching Knicks games,
like oh, D Wade with a haircut looks good.
I like that, growing out the hair.
Right?
He looks younger.
I was like that's good for you.
- [Big] You're still good.
- Yeah, you're still good.
So, 31, so how about
when you were growing up,
who were the new guys?
Scarface is obviously more like--
- [Big] Scarface, but no--
- But he was already
even a generation older.
- [Big] Talking 'bout
Pac, Biggie, UGK, Outkast,
Three 6 Mafia, probably (mumbling)--
- [Gary] Yeah, the whole LA
Reed Atlanta thing was just
so game changing.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It was like
Motown all over again.
- It was crazy, man.
And obviously, talking about
Snoop and people like that.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- But the beauty of
growing up in a small town,
'cause I'm from
Mississippi, in Mississippi,
is that radio played the top
10 records from everywhere.
But where I was from.
So, I got a good understand
of East Coast and West Coast
and what that feels like in tempos
and how that music sounded.
So when it came time to do
features and work with people,
I understood the science of
where they were coming from
and what made sense for people.
So, that was the benefit
of people not playing music
from where I was from.
- [Gary] So being
independent, the release here,
direct to consumer?
And then what?
- Man.
We keep pushing it.
- [Gary] Digital?
- Yeah, of course.
(speakers drowning each other out)
- [Man] And major artists are
showing a lot of support--
- [Gary] I saw.
- [Man] Really doing well.
- Go ahead, dude.
- Branding right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I spent so long, 'cause
I was always raised
as let someone else toot your horn.
You don't do it yourself.
- [Gary] Humility.
- Yeah, right.
And so--
- [Gary] And so, this new world.
- Yeah, and I run into a thing
where, and he gonna tell you
he's like brother, you
need to Tweet something.
You need to IG--
- [Gary] And it's not your natural state.
Let me tell you, as somebody
who goes the complete
other way, and peacocks.
(laughing)
It's probably the way you
feel about your music, man.
I feel so good about what
I'm saying, that I'm willing
to take the heat.
- Okay.
- [Gary] You know how many
people don't put out music
'cause they don't wanna take the heat?
Most of them.
- [Man] Most of 'em.
- [Gary] So, you need to
not talk when he wants
you to, 'cause it's smart strategy.
You need to find a way to when
you feel something to talk.
- Okay.
- Because if you, right?
If you can convert it in the
way you think about music,
the reason I'm putting
out so much shit is I got
something to say.
- [Big] I'm talking with you, man.
I'm talking with everybody in this room.
That's easy.
- So, listen--
- [Big] Talking into that, it's like fuck.
- So maybe you take the
strategy that I took.
Listen, if you did a fucking
Instagram story right now
and said I'm taking an
intern to be my videographer,
I'm not gonna pay you shit,
and you get to follow me around
and make video, follow me and
make videos and put it out,
yeah, fucking 10,000
people raising their hand.
You know how many people
would rip their arm off
that love you more than life to do that?
And you'll be like, you're
learn and this and that,
you should do that.
I can see that you're
comfortable in this kind of,
I thought this was gonna be
the hardest thing I ever did
'cause I was like, two
years ago, when I decided
to film everything I did, I'm
like, that's some douchey-ass
shit, right, like I was like,
how am I gonna explain that?
You know?
But I just knew it was right.
And that's, listen, it's
all about putting players
in a position to succeed.
In music, in sports, in business.
When somebody wants to become a producer
'cause they just wanna be a
producer, but they're really
a writer, it gets fucked up.
You gotta do your thing.
If it's not your thing
to self start and Tweet
and put up on Instagram,
then build around you.
I'm too busy.
I'm running a big-ass company.
So, I need them following
me around and filming.
So, I surround myself with
people, just like you've got
people around you that can
do other things, you need
somebody collecting content.
You're doing a lot of interesting shit.
Do you know how fucking
amazing it would be right now
to put out a 47-minute
documentary on Facebook
of those two years.
Short haired K.R.I.T.
(laughing)
But you know?
- [Big] Yeah, yeah.
- All this magic lost in time.
Like in the world that I live in, my dome,
imagine all those videos
we could be watching
of when Pac and Biggie were friends.
- [Big] Oh, my god.
- You know how just fun this is.
My man, you and I are gonna
sit down and eat some food
in 13 years, and pull up
our phone, or whatever,
and watch this.
- [Big] Yeah.
When I still had the hair.
(laughing)
- That's amazing.
So, I call it documenting versus creating.
You're an artist, so I
imagine through your head,
when you're putting out a
Tweet, you're probably putting
that extra layer--
- [Big] Oh, my god.
(speakers drowning each other out)
Bro!
I done sent it to him
or sent it to my girl,
and been like, yo, can I say something?
Or is this okay?
I go through--
- Overthinking it from an artistic level.
- [Big] I can't help it.
- I respect that, and I
don't want you to help it,
but I wanna create a
framework that allows you
to put out, and by the
way, let me go on a real,
crazy left turn on you.
You're just gonna like having
this when you're an old man
because your kids are
gonna be able to watch it.
- [Man] It's real.
- Super real.
And I don't even wanna get
into the way I think about shit
which AI and virtual reality.
In the world that I live
in, my kids, my great,
great grandkids, long after
I'm gone are gonna sell
this meeting, sell it, as virtual reality,
and they're gonna be
actually sitting right there,
'cause they think you're
cool, 'cause they think
I'm cool 'cause I'm
their great grandpappy,
and they're gonna sell it.
Yeah, it's crazy.
But I promise you, the guy
that drew Batman never thought
in 70 years there's gonna be
billion dollar movies made.
You can't project that far out.
But I can, a little bit.
A little bit, a little bit.
- [Big] You gotta go the distance.
- Documenting versus creating, K.R.I.T.
Anything that creates friction
for you, he already knows,
you're not gonna do it.
So, you're just gonna be.
So hack.
I think it's this.
I think you guys do some
sort of out, like one post,
and then people look at it, and be like,
interview three kids,
feel good about them,
make sure it's not just star
fucking and they're like.
That's what we do.
We get thousands of entries every time.
We gotta new person, we vet.
It will work for you, man.
Think about how much fun
it's gonna be for them.
Imagine you're a K.R.I.T.
fan, and now you're on tour.
Now, you're just film, like
you're living the dream.
- [Man] And we create those
experiences all the time.
- [Big] And we just don't--
- Every day, and there's interesting ones.
This is an unusual one.
Then there's on stage, then
there's another unusual one.
then there's the moment
where you're just walking
down the street and somebody
tells you this song did
this for them.
Captured.
And you decide to put that on Instagram
because you thought something.
And then you start getting used to it.
And then different shit.
And then you start creating.
Off the interaction, you
start looking at the camera,
making a point.
You start getting feedback.
Your social media grows 'cause of this.
And then people are leaving
comments, and you're getting
that feedback and it just...
Right?
It's counter punching.
You start reacting.
- It's been a difficult
thing and a challenge.
Even earlier on.
- [Gary] Did people think
you waited too long?
- No, on the low.
Oddly enough, I was scared.
- What do you think, Boyd?
- [Boyd] What do you mean?
For the album?
- For the album, yeah.
- [Gary] Two years is
like, in a world where
people are putting out mixed tapes.
- [Man] I can tell you that his fans were
consistently asking--
- Yeah, it got to a point where pictures.
Don't post no pictures, even.
- We knew that our project
was coming so we knew
the music was coming, we
didn't post on purpose.
But it was a consistent ask.
Where you at, where you at, where you at.
So, yeah, definitely.
- And music changes so much.
- So fast.
- Two years.
- But the beauty of--
- That's always, to be
very frank, that's the shit
that always scares me.
'Cause you get crippled by that.
I'm older.
That Dre project.
That was like, took
for, it never happened.
(laughing)
It never happened.
- [Big] Yeah, it never happened.
- I was like, and this is
pre-Internet, back in the
early Internet, and I was
like when is it coming?
(laughing)
Went through all of, went through life.
Like one thing you know.
- [Big] Oh, my god.
- And to that point, man.
Some of the stuff that was
in your head two years ago,
shit does change quick.
- [Big] But it game me the
opportunity to do as much
as I wanted to to a song right now.
- Good for you.
- [Big] No song's on that
album like oh, I wish
I woulda done that.
- Good.
You needed to do that.
- [Big] I needed it,
and both of the albums--
- And do you think that's
always how you're gonna need it
or do you think now that
you did it this way,
it gives you like, (sighing)
okay, did it that way once.
- No, I think now I can
create like this now.
Because the two years was figuring out how
to work with musicians, how
to get out of my comfort zone.
How to not record in my
house the whole time.
I get to go to other studios
to get creative criticism
and not take it so personally
that I don't wanna do
the song anymore.
(laughing)
So, I needed that.
And so now, going into the
next one is gonna be like
we weren't wrong.
And that's the first
thing that I realized.
Like man, we're at a time
when people are telling me
people don't wanna hear
that kinda shit, bro,
they just want a song for the radio.
And I'm like, brother, I got this record
that's about life and I wasn't wrong.
Like no, people are hurting.
It's a human thing.
Superheroes when we go
to work, but when we
by ourselves, we trying to figure it out,
and to put all that in my
album and to make music
like that is very necessary,
and there's a space for me.
- [Gary] Good for you, man.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] As long as you
understand your process, man.
- I get it, now.
I'm happy making music,
and it's no restrictions.
And I'm independent,
which makes it easier.
- [Gary] Crazy cool, yeah.
- [Boyd] I was just
telling K.R.I.T. earlier,
I was listening to this song or that song
and it really touched me, and that's why,
to answer your question, too, an artist
like him doesn't get hurt
too hard waiting a long time
'cause the music is so real.
It's not like catchy or
vibey or of the moment.
His music is touching your heart.
- Instead of me rapping just
to be rapping so you learn
these words on...
(laughing)
- I'm on it.
Hell yeah, thank you, my man.
- It's basically me telling you
about my life in transparency.
Which is easier for me to do
that sometimes, and again,
like with the cameras,
music is my therapy.
And so, when I'm dropping these songs,
it's literally forgetting
that at the moment
that I wrote it I was
going through something
and putting that out there for the world,
hoping somebody relates.
- Are you thinking about
the thing that I'm?
A big thing in me in
advertising while we popped was
I think the market's always right.
And I mean 100%.
I've never sat in the moment of my career
in anything I've done, from
my dad's liquor business
to me being a public persona.
If it didn't work, they
were right, I was wrong.
And as I've spent a lot
more time with artists,
and I don't mean just hip hop artists,
I mean the 300 people in
my creative department,
my artists, the ego stops
them from the humility
that becomes their strength.
So, one thing I've been
really interested in is
the notion of sitting
and listening to albums.
And then understanding
they want one of the
songs to be the single.
Because it's the one that
wrote that meant the most.
I do it, too.
There's some shit I talk about.
Patience.
I want more than life for all
these 30 year old and unders
to have patience, 'cause they can win.
They can win if they're not short cutting.
True confidence.
Like why do you need things?
Oh, 'cause you're insecure
and you wanna get girls
with it or you wanna show
somebody that you made it.
That insecurity stops you
from really getting there.
Right?
So, there's things I'm passionate about.
So, when I make content
around that, I'm like
I hope this goes, and when
it doesn't, I'm fine with it.
I just collect it.
So, you're talking about
something with A Boogie
that I thought was
interesting and something
I've been thinking a
lot about as we continue
to have these meetings, and
I'm trying to help bring value,
is the notion of the single.
So, this comes out.
I'm dying to know the
meetings of this crew
and definitely dying to know what's going
through your head for weeks
of like what's gonna be
the single, and I don't know if that's how
you think about it, but
damn, 90%, 95% or maybe 100%,
and definitely if you got a label.
- [Big] But we don't--
- I know you don't.
Definitely if you do, they're
picking what's the single.
But even as an artist, I
still think everybody's got
a favorite child.
- [Big] Yeah.
(laughing)
- Go ahead.
- I don't know
if it's so much picking
the singles, more as,
yes, you have lead singles.
Absolutely.
- So, let's just start
with that for a minute.
I'm fascinated by that in the
environment we now live in.
That made a lot of sense
to me when radio play.
But that's, you know how some
shit just gets carried over
'cause that's the way it was?
- [Man] Right.
- This is not a final thought,
this is my brainstorm.
I think I know what the lead single is.
The ones that they told
us are the lead singles.
There's a way to harness
the reality of the market,
and you have to have pure
humility that does not come
natural to anybody in the field of art.
Go ahead, please.
- [Man] With his two singles, it was more,
from artistic standpoint.
- That was what he was
most passionate about.
- [Man] You following what I'm saying?
- Of course.
By the way, of course.
There's only one of two things.
There's the business
people saying this one,
'cause it's gonna sell shit,
and then there's the artist
or the artistic people
saying this is the one
that means the most.
I get that.
I'm about the third one
which is the fucking market.
- Right.
So now, we put those two
out as a launching pad,
but we put the project out on top of it,
so now, the market, like 1999 is a single
that's really coming back from the market.
- [Gary] I get it.
(speakers drowning each other out)
Of course I do.
- [Big] In itself, it
wasn't what we put out.
- And by the way, we all know that.
That's happened for years
for people's albums.
- [Big] But again, one
being independent, this is
the first time I was like bro
this need to be the first one.
- Mm-hmm.
(mumbling)
Yeah, you've been wanting
to scratch that itch.
Yeah, yeah.
- Board-room meeting
and they was like well, well we like--
- But that hook is gonna work on radio.
I get it.
- [Big] And I know what
you talking about because--
- It's an interesting thing.
- The idea of being an independent artist
or when you underground and
you're trying to figure out,
your shit is jamming, and in your mind,
and everybody's telling
you it's better than
what's on the radio but
you can't get on the radio.
Yeah, it's like damn,
but people be like man,
I hate that song, but they
find themselves listening
to it and knowing it
because it's on the radio.
I'm trying to figure out who
the hell is still wanting
this song played.
So, you got a point to something--
- There's something else
I've been thinking about.
I wanna throw at you since
the vibes I'm feeling.
This is something, you haven't
heard this one yet from me.
- [Big] Oh, let's go.
(laughing)
- I got one, I got one.
I got one that I've been
really, 'cause deep down,
I wish I was a rapper,
and then shit would be
so much more fun.
I would be fucking.
I just wish I knew how to flow.
I believe you.
- I got beats.
We'll get in the studio.
- I believe you.
I actually weirdly think I'm
gonna try to train myself
into figuring it out because I've got it
but I don't have it.
You know what I mean?
Like I got it--
- [Big] It's here, but coming out--
- It's why I do what I do and it works,
and you see it, it's working in culture.
It's just not done through, anyway, this.
I'm dying to see your perspective on this.
I have a concept that I haven't seen.
Song comes out, album comes
out, project comes out.
Something pops.
In movies, they come out
with number two quick.
You put out Guardians of
the Galaxy, you're like
what the fuck happened?
It blows up in the theater,
they're fucking in production
on number two from the bat.
(speakers drowning each other out)
- [Man] Just like Fast and the Furious.
- [Big] Right after it.
- So, for me, again, back to lyrics.
You write a song, it's
about you're going through
with your girl, with your best friend,
with somebody sick in
your family, and it goes.
Well, it's been some time
in between you writing that
and now it happening.
To write the update and piggy
back off the momentum is
something I've never seen.
There's something there.
Song goes.
It meant something.
You know a lot of stuff
goes that doesn't mean,
but it meant something.
The words.
- [Man] So, quick question.
- Yes, sir.
- [Man] Would that not
be considered the remix?
- [Big] No, because remix
is other people's ideas
on top of your song.
- [Man] It could be your idea, too.
- The remix is some
form of a collaboration
that building of the
equity of the popularity.
What I'm referring to,
especially if you write--
- [Man] Oh, you're
saying a different song?
- A different, but literally
is like the name is
like The Follow Up or What Happened, or,
ready for this?
Ready for this?
Ready for this.
- Next week,
I'm gonna do that shit.
- I do believe that.
- [Big] That's right.
- I think, K.R.I.T., I
think right here, right now,
we're creating a genre
called What Happened, colon,
and the name of the song.
The Follow Up.
That's interesting artistically.
- [Big] It's also a little
dangerous, creatively, right?
- Go ahead.
(mumbling)
What's that?
- [Man] I think you did that,
three albums, like Reloaded,
Rewatched, she did that
like three albums--
- Yes, but I'm going, yeah, exactly.
I am, I am.
I'm saying, I'm saying, this is out 1999,
then you write 2000.
Or like something.
There's something, so what
people don't realize is
distribution's been commoditized.
The process that Michael Jackson had
to go through doesn't exist.
You put this project
out, and to your point,
something's popping, we're
getting feedback back.
Now, back to your point.
Artistically, if you can't
get the momentum to write
The Follow Up or The Update,
mazel tov, but if you can,
now you're breaking new ground.
I think for hip hop, it could become...
There used to not be
anything called the remix.
I'm old.
I grew up, there was no remix.
There isn't something called
The Follow Up or The Update,
but I think it could happen.
The speed in which you can do things,
that fucking excites,
because I'm in it for,
you have to understand
who I am as a listener,
I'm in it for the story.
- [Man] Right.
So, yeah, that'd be dope.
- Right?
(speakers drowning each other out)
- [Big] But how do you
keep it genuine, though?
That's the key.
Because what's happens--
- You know what?
I'm not worried about you.
I'll tell you why.
Can I answer how you're
gonna keep it genuine?
You don't know any other options.
That's why you asked the question.
So honestly, if I was part
of this crew, I'd be like yo,
99's popping, or this song's
popping or that song's popping.
You got some?
First of all, when it's your crew or you,
you know your life.
If nothing's happened since you wrote that
about the baby-mamma drama
or the grandpa or the city,
well, there's nothing to talk about.
But if there is.
- [Big] Mm-kay.
- Right?
So, one thing you'll love,
it was the first thing
I said to you, and this
is where I'm connecting
with you right now.
I've never said anything
I don't believe in
in my fucking life.
So, in a weird way, even
though I'm such a business man,
I have that one attachment with artists.
I've never said a damn fucking
word I don't believe in.
There's been opportunities.
I could be making a lot of
money talking about some shit.
So, I get you.
But if there's something to say.
- [Man] Say it.
(laughing)
- And take advantage of
culture that we now live in
because people have not
seen this white space
that I'm seeing.
- [Man] Hey!
- [Man] I got an idea.
- You do.
- [Man] I got the idea.
We'll talk about it.
- Okay, good.
(clapping)
Interesting, right?
You know why I love that
and why I pitched it to you?
Is 'cause I'm feeling your vibe.
That's art.
Because now you're inventing some shit.
Now you're going over
here and being like yo.
This is a whole new territory of thing,
and as for a writer,
that's incredible because
that flexibility to write,
back to what you said,
sat on this for two years
because I don't feel
like I have to go back and say I did it.
But as you know, sometimes
when you're telling a story,
there's an update.
- [Big] Always, yeah.
- And so to me, for a lot
of the stories I listen to,
every day, I'm like oh, what happened?
With that girl that broke your heart?
Or what happened?
Okay, it's been a year since
grandpa died and he was
your fucking North Star.
How you doing?
What about writing the fact
that you visited the cemetery?
What?
'Cause it's stories.
- [Man] Mm-hmm.
- There's something there.
To me, it's that, something pops,
and there's an actual story?
Get the fuck in the
studio and get that out.
I can see a tsunami.
- [Boyd] That's surprising to the fans.
- Yeah, that's--
- [Boyd] Giving them what they want.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That is what they want.
- The connection of, as
far as people I've seen,
my life I talk about in my
music, and the understanding
of sorts, right.
- Well, that's why it would work for you.
You're not just talking
about going to club
and having fun, which is great.
When you're telling
stories, life didn't stop.
- [Big] It definitely didn't.
- And this story might've been finished.
But this story might be just starting.
And if that song went, and
you've got a couple more lines
to add to the equation,
you see where I'm going.
I see it.
I'm looking for you.
'Cause I'm looking deeply
through his glasses,
and I'm watching his eyes.
This is interesting shit.
I'm not fooling around here.
This is something different.
- [Boyd] That's fun.
I'm gonna tell you all
right, I like that a lot.
- All right, go ahead.
Drink one.
Those things are like fucking $14.
(laughing)
Drink that Dirty Lemon.
What's up, my man?
- [Man] I was just saying,
he's a story teller.
- That's what it is, man.
- [Man] Exactly what you're
saying because if you came up
with a follow up, your
fans would be all in that.
You know what I'm saying?
(speakers drowning each other out)
- [Big] That's dope.
- [Man] That's crazy.
See, but now, we done put
it out there, and if people,
somebody's gonna, that's already done.
(mumbling)
- Honestly, that to me is the best part.
To your point.
I'm gonna put it out
because I don't want you
to have the pressure of that.
That's just what's fun.
That's the zeitgeist, but that's real.
And you have an advantage
in the way you communicate
to the point of some people write things
and they're trying to go backwards
on saying some funny shit
to hope it pops.
Put some great beat on it,
let me make up a fucking word
and see if it can go.
You're writing about your life.
- [Big] Yeah, man.
- And when you write about
your life, you've got
a big advantage for the model
that I've been sitting on
in my head.
- [Big] That's crazy, though.
- It's interesting, right?
- [Man] Ah, we gonna chop up after this.
(mumbling)
- [Big] For sure.
- [Man] Man.
I appreciate that.
(laughing drowning out speaker)
- [Big] As a creator, and
especially now, trying
to be inspired and figure out
a way to keep doing something.
- To me, I think the thing
that you're gonna get to is
you're gonna want to get to
probably where I am creatively
in marketing and communications,
which is after you get good
at your craft, after you scratched
a couple of those itches,
you wanna start inventing shit.
And there's only so
many ways you can invent
within the box that you already know.
You're trying to scratch that itch.
I think that we haven't thought
about music dimensionally
enough to understand
what the new distribution
channels have awarded us.
That's why when I talk
about what I just said,
it's a big idea.
Because it's staying within the confines,
but it's creating new territory
that hasn't been there,
much like a remix.
Or like collaborations
with a country star.
Or an influencer.
There's just new little things that could
never be done before.
Like the music video.
There wasn't that in 1972.
- [Big] And all of a sudden--
- Then there was.
Then it became the art.
Then there wasn't.
And to me, that's what's
so, but, when I know
somebody who's writing real
shit, that is super interesting.
A project that took two years to come out.
A song that resonates.
A truth that there is a follow
up story, not fabricated,
that you can get generated about.
And then it comes out 11 days later
and everybody's been feeling that song,
and now you're telling what happened.
You're feeding 'em.
(laughing)
- [Big] Wow, okay.
- I betcha didn't think
that was coming today.
- [Big] Definitely no.
(laughing)
(speakers drowning each other out)
- [Big] He was like go, like okay.
I'm thinking to myself like studio time.
(mumbling)
- Bro.
- My man.
Oh yeah, let's get this pictures, too.
Right.
All right, going vertical on this one.
Hope you guys enjoyed it.
Hope you loved it.
Leave your three cents in the comments.
Subscribe.
Tag homies.
Share this everybody in
hip hop that loves hip hop
because K.R.I.T. and I
chopped it up for real.
(hip hop music)